قصتنا اليوم مشاهدينا عن الشاب السعودي
خالد السنيد الذي عاش لي اكثر من ثلاثه
عقود دون والدته المصريه بعد انفصالها عن
والده وانقطاع اخبارها خالد كبر ولم يتخلى
عن حلمه بلقاء والدته التي لم يعيش معها
كثيرا سعى لذلك سنوات طويله واخيرا كان
اللقاء الذي انهى كل سنين الثنائي والبعد
انفعلوا لقاء جميل جمع الابن بوالدته وطغى
الفرحه ودموعها على كل شيء واليوم في صباح
العربيه سنكون معهما لنبارك لهما هذا
الاجتماع مجددا
لنسمع قصه الفراق الصعبه
[موسيقى]
التعبير انت يعني هل حاولتي انك تحاولي
تعثري على ابنك كل هذه السنين وكيف كان
شعورك لما اجاك الخبر والتليفون بانه هو
موجود وعم بدور عليك وبده يشوفك
السلام عليكم انا كنت كنت دائما بتصل بيه
باهله
كنت على طول بسال عليه بتصل بالتليفون ما
حدش بيرضى يديني ويقولوا لي لا احنا قلنا
له ان انت متي فما كانش ما كانش يعني ما
كانش ينفع ان انا اكلمه يقولوا لي لا ما
ينفعش احنا قلنا له ان انت متي فانا ما
ينفعش ان انت تكلميه
فكنت دايما اقول لهم
طب اسمع صوته مش هقول لهم ان انا مش هقول
لهم ان انا امه بس اسمع صوته
كان برضو في رفض منهم
فعشان كنت عاوزه اروح السفاره بس ادام هم
رافضين ما ينفعش ان انا اروح السفاره لما
شفتيه اول مره بعد ثلاثين سنه ثلاثه عقود
وانت وهو بعيد عنك ايه المشاعر كيف عرفتي
اول شيء عرفت ازاي انا ما كنتش مصدقه في
الاول ان هو قالوا لي ان ابنك ابنك جه
وتدور عليك وللقاكي فما كنتش مصدقه اكن
انا في حلم يعني شعور فرحه مع ان انا مش
مصدقه ده فعلا حقيقه يعني ده انا مش دي
حقيقه اللي بتحصل دي مش مصدقه طيب تركي
انا بدي اسالك يعني انت كيف كيف قدرت
تتوصل وكيف عرفت بانه والدتك يعني على قيد
الحياه كيف قدرت تعرف مكانها وشو كان
شعورك بهديك اللحظه
[موسيقى]
موضوع يعني كان مهم مره مدير شو الرعايه
السعوديه استاذ محمد البريكي والاستاذ
ونابه الاستاذ محمد السبيعي كلهم والله ما
قصروا معي من ناحيه انهم لقوا الوالده
وابحثوا عنها بالبدايه الى الملف الصحي
حقها يعني بشروك
[موسيقى]